[Music]
pilot to Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
uncle Joey checking in with the [__]
masses pilot to Bombardier
it's a beautiful [__] day to be
alive you follow me
we're going deep so get ready right tell
grandma to make extra mashed potatoes
you're taking that [__] Easter dinner
to new heights today you understand hear
another word fat [__] until they see you
in action
happy Stu you bad [__] and
still today Jeff Sessions could suck my
dick uncle Joey here April 1st whatever
April Fool's for these [__] Gentiles
me we swing dick everyday just wanted to
check him will you let you know I didn't
forget about you [__] we got in
the rail reefers for you today we have
this [__] from [__] car over
tremendous we got some [__] that ain't
ready yet tremendous we got some stuff
from Sun Center where we things from son
said if I don't mess with nobody else no
more they don't give a [__] they got
weed limits over there that you're going
through a [__] coma that's what I'm
looking for
coma weed oh gee coma if you got some
call you uncle Joey but besides that
it's a he beautiful day to be alive may
be time to pop a little edible to get
the [__] blood going this time ink
you stick on fire
and that's it and that's that I just
want to check in with you to make sure
you're all right I don't want to you
guys I Joey you don't fine odd dog I've
been [__] busy I usually fill up my
tank twice so we are month this week I
filled it up once cuz I was on fire all
week so forgive me
the body of Christ compels you he's
risen he's [__] come from the dead
that's it at this point two thousand
years ago Jesus was pushing a [__]
Boulder
when he got out that Mary Magdalene game
a bad sous column Inc and here we are
today you're following me but hey who
needs a [__] history lesson let's get
down I came to get down you can take it
down you want to [__] around here it's
gonna be a great week gonna [__] what
they tell you oh yeah let's do this [__]
do this [__] there's that in [__]
waste your time on Easter they come here
talk to you about the [__] weather if
we're gonna get down let's get [__]
get down get those pipes in the field 18
go [__] yourself go do your homework a
little hat with a propeller rounded or
something it kills me just [__] Frank
Stallone dude what the [__] that he ever
do that goofy bastard we used to go to
this gym he used to be there he don't
like rap music
so whenever the owner wanted to get rid
of him he put on [__] rap music and
he'd [__] leave crying like a little
puzzle he is Frank [__] Stallone
what's wrong with him he's a [__]
brother you just got a check from your
older brother you shut the [__] up you
[__] Momo anyway don't get me started
I love spending Sunday afternoons where
you [__] people just to let you know
we're here we're here with we were
representing you understand me again my
condolences they buried Cleo's father
yesterday so if you got a minute hit her
up check in with her like I said before
when one of us is hurting all of us are
hurt that's where the true family's
about
but you already [__] know that you
follow me I don't even have a family you
guys adopted me I adopted you and look
what we end up with [__]
I smoked some of this [__] here this
should have put your [__] calm nice
with the yellow but we're doing a
podcast today five o'clock Pacific time
I don't know what time that is we're
able to [__] you people are figure that
go to your [__] right foot clap there
and look out world [__] clocks and
figure out what time with his I ain't
got enough to [__] tell you I don't
know nothing about nothing all I know is
reefer and [__] wait watch your
points right now that's it
I'll be an Albuquerque New Mexico
Thursday and [__] Friday it's already
sold out but I'll be lurking you're
following me so if you see me just pass
me a [__] butter that mixed reefer
with meth and [__] like that's we get
the party started then two weeks I'm at
the [__] beautiful Columbus Ohio
funny bone
Friday night lates already sold that for
you pot headed [__] but bring
everything you got
somebody's going on hospital that night
you follow me it might even be your new
uncle Joey who gives a [__] but what he
look we're the most important thing is
it's a Lord's Day and we get to get
together and talk like [__] gentlemen
and ladies you're following me no
[__] no who gives a [__] about all
that [__] you know it's all about us I'm
with you you're with me and these
[__] ain't with us you follow
me we're on our own [__] planet take
it off suck your dick when you walk in
the room you got the biggest dick in the
room who's gonna stop it who's gonna
stop you some [__] Gentile excuse me
we don't write your language I don't
give a [__] what you're like I'm
imposing my will on you like let's get
in opening 77 I got time to [__]
worry about feelings you follow me we're
playing for keeps [__] it's a
whole new week 22 push-ups write down
your goals and let these [__]
know what's in your heart that's it
plain and simple
if you walk around the green with these
[__] morons but you soon you become
one of these [__] morons flops them
and they're [__] this is my [__]
world [__] you follow me uncle Joey
style the sink or a mile I'll be in
Tempe Arizona and then [__]
Providence Rhode Island they just added
a second show on a Thursday night and
then you got [__] the stress factory
in Jersey I have not heard from Netflix
but [__] it
it don't matter it's just the [__]
you're following if they say yes it's
good and if they say no Mamma Mia I
think I still and life still goes on and
we're still getting funnier and we're
still taking it to the hoop every
[__] day that's what we do I know
don't mean nothing I know means you're
closer to a [__] yes that's it
so don't worry about nothing enjoy your
[__] day with your family today
you're lucky that you have one give them
all a hug telling me you're a bad mother
[__] tell them you're a new man cuz
you got a new uncle in the family uncle
Joey adopted and that means when you
walk in a place now you'd have to call
your masseur and rub your elbows and
light your cigarettes and [__]
Oh what is the best part of my week just
kickin it with you guys right here no
pre Church no nothing just getting the
head ready for the following week you
follow me all these Catholics are
walking around hurting Jesus who gives a
[__]
make a [__] living it's a Jew holiday
- you don't see them stop but what do
you think who puts these [__] poor
Mexicans on a free Street theirselves
[__] fruit anyway let's do one more
[__] like I said this [__] it's
tremendous I just got this drop top I
got to put it under a heat lamp to get
the folk patois that [__] weed so it
gets like a [__] the dust of that as
I like to call it anyway let's do
another bowl what the [__] the guys
right here this smoked a half a joint
oh my god we love them we micro dose get
the [__] out of here
[__] rocks tails on AMC and I'm here
with you [__] just like you know
it's all about you it's your world these
punk-ass [__] are visiting if you
don't let them know he's gonna let them
know like I said before what do you
think the Bluebird of happiness when I'm
knock on your door and say here's a
million dollars that's only in the
[__] movies you wanted you gotta go
out then take it [__] so we enjoy
your little Thanksgiving whatever the
[__] it is Easter dinner with your
family thought that that and at six
o'clock get back to being a [__]
mental thief you're ready to walk in and
just impose these [__] just let
them know let them know dog because if
you don't let em know I'm nobody entire
publicist that day I'm stumped
but it don't matter we go to the [__]
limousine let's do one more out of
respect for the ones who can't [__]
be doing one more
whoops way home on the [__] of way go as
did you said play though anyway I love
you [__]
you know me dog my heart's in my [__]
hand I don't give a [__] no more
I know celebrity I ain't no I'm a
[__] dirty comic who don't give a
[__] I got felonies and I ain't cleanse
them you know why I ain't doing jury
duty how am I gonna judge a fellow
brother who the [__] am I to [__]
tell some guy he's guilty and not guilty
[__] your on behalf of felon I carry a
gun but I don't vote you know we do it
besides that happy Easter to you and
your [__] families all over the
world from Frankie bark and Australia -
my man Bob willingness and [__]
Chicago - my name peeps down in Austin
Bobby sharing running the church the
okie spooky - my girl [__] Cleo you
know your mother [__] are and I'm
down Leon Vega you got the list goes on
and on you [__] a church
[__] ambassadors so you gotta act
like you know I'm saying I know people
bothering Leon they wanted to go out
need coke rocks off chicks [__]
Leon's are no man he's focusing on cards
he's gonna start raping them every
[__] night six seven thousand a night
how do I know cuz I know I [__] been
there when you been there you been there
I'm a 55 year old going on 90 and
cocaine years but anyway I love you
[__] with all my heart
if I can't see in Albuquerque the
tickets are sold out but I'll see you
[__] in Columbus ready they're
gone if you don't think we're eatin
edibles the whole weekend on stage you
got another thing coming this like Judas
Priest and [__] Haiti one you follow
me another thing coming was 83 I'm sorry
I'm walked maybe I'm a little [__] up
but anyway Happy Easter
enjoy your family don't forget the
church what's happening now tonight
five o'clock and don't forget for you to
do two [__] wanna win
tournaments
I got rash guards up on Joey Diaz dotnet
this is your chance right now some dude
came up to me that day [__] pull the
key out of his bag and showed me a patch
on it I'm gonna started crying
there's just savages you got the spirit
and that's it and that's that remember
love your family make somebody's day and
stay black cuz you're a bad [__]
who told you I told you take it on the
model Orion acquaintances intent even
came I might tell our Pingala Lea he met
that that I language autumn cool Alya
poor little Eagle your chemo he knew
there are some TC metallic foil Araya my
mama in the - Oi
alright stay black I love you
[__]